[Music]
it's not funny okay
what about this
[Music]
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by
dot com
head over to the shop support the fight
and buy some cool threads
it's the tits pajamas.com
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
strangers
hmm
one-handed sit well it's really hard to
button a shirt with one hand why would
you do that why maybe i should just let
my freak flag fly
hey come on please get an episode back
women women are shouting their abortions
why can't i show a little bit of my uh
my chest hair your slurry you should
really be unbuttoning nothing no i
should be then i must be eating a burger
on the floor
um
what a talented
oh
so hoffy uh look we have a lot to get to
today we're going to be talking about
the texas abortion law the ins and outs
of that the woke military because
they've been relieving traditional
members of the military of duty while uh
looking to recruit woke lesbians as one
does in the military that's how you win
wars yeah exactly you win wars with
dad issues and plaid shirts from orvis
um and we're talking about mexico's
abortion policies
i believe that was in the article
imagine that they're in the pacific oh
no
they are in the foresters
so
the promo code is crowder comeback you
can join mug club yesterday we did an
extra full like hour and 20 minutes long
yesterday every day we do more content
and of course it's the only thing that
allows us to continue the show because
we don't get paid nothing on the youtube
which is fine which is fine we're cool
with that just let us speak freely uh
but first gerald a is here how are you
sir i'm well how are you i'm okay
feeling better after yesterday i'm
feeling a little i'm out of effort it's
still i have to hit people don't have to
hit the mute button when you guys are
talking and breathe and then my rib cage
kind of starts popping but uh yeah you
know i'm grateful oh good it's a day
above ground
so you're saying if we're saying i feel
well protected by our lesbian military
well that's good you just i feel like
you just throw all the lesbians at them
first and then you're thinking
50 years from now where someone's out
there burning the flag like hey there
are a lot of lesbians who died for your
right to burn that flag
burning the gay flag
freedom ain't free it costs the blood
of lgbtq aip uh quarter black garrett is
here how are you i'm i'm sick he's sick
he's gonna leave hopefully none of us
get that uh that mew variant
over 100 people in los angeles county
who'd have thought that there could be
more variants it's almost like it'll
never end uh mr landau dave is here he
has some shows coming up by the way
this weekend spokane club in washington
and then october 1st carnegie music is
that i mean is that a hall that is a
hole that's how popular you are oh well
people where can people get the tickets
uh they can go to carnegie music uh
homestead google carnegie music
homestead and then this uh at noon it
just scrolled past me there you go but
yes this uh don't go to carnegie hall
it'll just be a six-year-old ben shapiro
playing schindler's list
yeah this is the stifle theater i
believe it's pronounced october 22nd in
celina kansas this
friday those tickets go on sale at noon
cst
so before we and i do want to hear the
best thing you can do again we've talked
about with youtube is is is commenting
so i want to know where you line up on
the texas abortion laws um
what you like what you dislike about it
i actually obviously support the
heartbeat component we'll talk about the
legal component which i'm not a huge fan
of just because i think it may be
written poorly and yeah in a way that
could be thrown out needs clarification
needs clarification uh that being said
if you think that it's extreme and you
support abortion up until and including
birth you're an evil person and that's a
lot of states
uh before we get to that though you
mentioned yesterday a muppet people were
asking about this if it was real a
muppet with hiv aids yes yeah from
sesame street africa
oh
no they were from africa well i wasn't
yeah i was doing the origin story well
no i'm saying well the origins africa
if this muppet were a fighter it would
be
fighting out of sesame street by way of
africa
she's she's she's only six so only six i
believe she got the aids because
somebody in her tribe was trying to cure
it
sucks
and people thought that we were making
it up because it was just a picture but
actually we did some digging and uh
here's a clip
just in case you think we were making it
up
oh and i also talked to them about hiv
and aids me too kami
talking and listening and helping people
to learn about hiv and aids are
two of the things i do a lot really
what's the other one
talk about my feelings with my friends
and family
when i am feeling sad or scared
and i like to talk to parents about how
important it is to listen to their
children you ever see a grown man naked
to take care of each other yes
i did not have sexual relations with
that muppet okay to hug someone who is
hid positive like me
i sure do cammy
that makes me very happy
that must again that must be the
apartheid muppet it has yeah i mean that
is a white muppet yellow signifies white
yes of course in muppet world unless it
had a deep or simpsons that's true and
it doesn't i'm thinking that uh
something happened between them that's
why he's looking so gaunt lately
and magic johnson hey stay away my
muppet man
wait wait
i'm sorry that was just him and hillary
uh anyway let's uh so
before we move on here talking about the
texas abortion law people asking are
going to be talking about the texas
voter laws uh right yeah devoted no oh
wait you need id ballot harvesting is
illegal
i don't care all right it's so very
clear we were covering this election
night obviously that law is these are
common sense voting reform laws if you
think that they're racist because black
people can't procure id
you're a racist we've changed my minds
on that topic all this is is legislation
to reflect what most people when pulled
on individual issues actually support i
don't need to waste time on it
golf clap that's my commentary good job
let's move on to
uh mexico
just decriminalized
abortion which kind of surprised me
really um but i believe we have uh a
clip they claimed it was
unconstitutional this is new amujera
mexico's supreme court unanimously ruled
on tuesday that penalizing abortion is
unconstitutional
the president of the country's highest
court described the decision as a
watershed moment for all women
especially the most vulnerable
so what about the baby women
doesn't really matter all that much so
much uh this is of course the left
another speculating that this will cause
people from texas to go south to procure
abortions that's a new talking point
where montezuma's thinning shears
well
i mean you'll get one you'll just also
be dead yeah yeah
it's like yeah the cartels yeah we're
gonna go there for abortions don't drink
the water ice cubes avoid pina coladas
but uh trust the stirrups joy ah
sure it'll work out joy read immediately
took to twitter to praise mexico saying
that they out
moderned texas uh okay okay sure look
and this is their standard
seriously
you out modern texas they allowed the
killing of children oh we out modern i
mean that's your standard of
modernity
we'll get into the whole segment about
following the science look
when you have people who say
menstruating persons uh
the science look behind you there's the
science i checked out a long time ago
exactly when you're praising mexico for
anything medically that is like a
reversion you should probably check
yourself a little bit oh yeah the
cartels i think are going to be doing
the abortions too and so they're going
to be totally capable of doing all of
that so if you're a guy who's
menstruating you're going to want to go
right to the hospital of course yes
exactly that's not what you think it is
preferably in america yes because we cut
you yeah
yeah they have a plus yeah
i'm pretty sure in mexico they don't
even have a word for transgender they're
really
okay
i don't know i don't have time for this
uh let's kill it
hombre
tolerance no no no do mean uh gross
yeah
i'm saying this because this is a
problem when you have leftist look i'm
not saying that but what the issue is
when you defend for example uh the
ideologies of islam and when you are
looking to import uh third world voters
from third world countries let's be
honest mexico is largely a third world
country these people make very little
money and my heart goes out to them but
the fact is catholic mexicans typically
don't support the left's values the same
thing with the black community if you
were to actually look at their polling
on individual social issues you would
think that it was a sam an oversampling
of republicans okay that's just a fact
so there you go you'll praise him with
abortion ask them about the lgbtq aip
ask the mexican supreme court about that
see where they line up ask them about
immigration laws ask them if if
non-native citizens can own waterfront
property ask them what happens if an
immigrant mexico burns a mexican flag
these are things the left doesn't want
they don't want to ask they just want to
praise the murderer more children
speaking of mexico stuff that's going on
there uh the feds intercepted a shipment
of fentanyl in houston hey enough to
kill 1.4
million
americans party time yeah and by the way
it's well known that most of the
fentanyl in the united states comes from
uh china and then a ship to mexico you
know some
yeah it does and ships and then they
mule it over here right right and what
people aren't realizing and this is what
i can't stand seeing online because some
comics had died recently because of it i
know tons of people now that have died
of fentanyl why they're like what the
cartel wants to kill people let me
explain yes they don't care it's all
about the deal they make right there and
the millions they make off of it there
is no shortage of new junkies every day
right that's why they don't mind getting
rid of the people that buy their product
yeah always be new ones like i just it's
not intense it's just they could they
don't care yeah exactly they're like
they make so much money they just end up
like i don't know put it in the wall i
guess we filled up the other walls yeah
yeah and it's by the way people talk
about the opioid crisis yeah right they
want to say we have an opioid crisis
here in the country which i have an
unpopular opinion and i think we've
we've swung too far the other way when
you have surgery and you have people who
actually can't get them right any pain
killers there is a use for it and i
think it was over prescribed but
synthetic opioids particularly those on
the street like fentanyl they are the
main driver of drug overdose from 2012
to 2019
and a pure kilo fentanyl goes for like
34 000 or something like that i pay 30.
you pay 30. yeah on the street so again
let's just talk about border security
because you care about the opioid crisis
there you go you can
and fentanyl has killed some pretty high
profile people in the past i can't think
of specific names
i can think of one but a few i'm not
going to name
well they just omar from the wire
yesterday two days ago that guy did
drugs yeah he died from drugs
[Laughter]
no way my point is my point is you think
you you can never spot him you know you
just know you just never know people
have addiction issues
uh so uh anyway china's making a killing
on this this again if you actually cared
about the opioid crisis it would be
crack down on china yeah and it would be
secure our borders this is not just an
issue of a voter base for democrats
that's how they see it this is a
security issue not only of crime
particularly in the uh southwestern
places like west texas not only with
just the drug cartels obviously offering
them but it's also uh an unsecured
border where terrorists can walk through
fentanyl can be transported
it can exacerbate the opioid crisis
children are trafficked this is uh yeah
hopefully an issue where everyone can
find some common ground of compact maybe
you don't like a wall
but maybe you understand that we
shouldn't be importing
migrants from these countries and by the
way uh making it a requirement according
to the cdc that they get ivermectin due
to parasites that's something that a lot
of people don't yeah that's right cdc
migrants from south america asia and
african nations all are recommended
ivermectin
it just makes common sense yes it does
the autocorrect on youtube just removed
it because the word oh no he's not uh
he's at the back in word
triple strikes
hey by the way the best thing you can do
uh to tune into the show people say
where we find you because we're often
not showing up in search uh or browse is
it's a live show monday through thursday
10 a.m eastern we always stream live you
can smash that like button and uh you
can subscribe to the podcast too in case
we ever get struck again here on youtube
some people like to listen they're
driving or something like that they
can't watch so the podcast is great yeah
itunes spotify or sorry apple spotify
android whatever it's basically
everywhere and we'll be taking your chat
on mug club in a little bit before we
move on to uh
some of the abortion stuff amazon just
tweeted this out over the weekend
what movie do you want to see the
all-female reboot of let's not even get
into the issue of the grammar of
amazon's tweet um yeah i'm gonna go
brokeback mountain
i'm pretty sure they've done that
i'm gonna do it over and over and over
it's true but it hasn't been widely
released okay
boys in the hood anybody boys
how about uh how about an all-male
suffragette movie there you go how about
an all-male league of their own like why
just why why why do they need this is
one of those we call it baseball though
stephen it would just be called
regular baseball we're good you tried it
you tried it with ghostbusters
we screwed up we trusted you that's it
didn't we tried it with the ocean's
franchise
pretty bad as well yeah so it's the
exact same thing well let's do saving
private ryan i want to see them storm
the beaches of course
they would be dead right before they get
off just to the second to get off the
boat yeah before they get off the boat
because women will be driving the boat
they just they just end up in ireland
what the [ __ ] are you doing here oh this
is gonna hurt
yeah it's just the water looks like that
it's not because of a battle it's just
because all their periods sink
aoc has some things to say to you sir oh
come on that that's that's all careful
how about the answer is none ever yeah
the answer is none the answer is i would
hope that women would want original
girls should have their own role models
not say hey i love uh i love uh i don't
know insert any role model here i love
that uh green lantern i love that they
created they created an all a female
superhero from the ground up and the mom
i was like well if it wasn't always a
woman what they kind of had to
appropriate it you have your things
don't try and turn everything into an
all-female and by the way this is
something else too they want to do for
example the all-black version of the
wonder years right yeah i have no
problem whatsoever
and i want to be clear with shows that
are one of my favorite shows growing up
was fresh prince of bel air yeah oh yeah
the best family matters used to play in
tgif so good uh
racist would call it the lead into step
by step but that's their issue
that's on them racists love patrick
duffy yes they do they do and they also
like cody yes
sasha mitchell who is a wife beater
that's right i don't know but here's the
thing so we talk there's b-e-t for
example yeah i did i was at a hotel
recently i was sitting there and i
realized b-e-t like their standards now
are so i'm like why is why is deep blue
c and because there are two black actors
and d clue c this is v
one of them gets killed immediately but
the point is
all of the ship the mainstream networks
right they're mixed blackish is on abc i
think fresh prince was on was it on fox
i don't know family matters nbc family
matters
you go back to the jefferson they're
mixed shows and then bet is racially
exclusive i don't understand why we're
at a point now where we need to co-opt
content that has just not even
necessarily been all white but been
mixed not necessarily even been all male
it would be pretty hard to find films
that are exclusively male that require
an all-female cast and then look
you wonder why young men feel it's not a
good thing to do this is a really bad
path you're going down you are going to
alienate 50 of the population when you
continue to vilify them they're going
when someone is blamed for something
despite no wrong doing of their own
you create animosity and this is
something is there is there any
equivalent to
think picture
a minority white country yeah any
country where whites are a minority okay
is there any white entertainment
television in any of those
nations
what if we did that today in here what
if we did it with the united
people on st channel hallmark channels
call yeah i believe i believe it's
called the nashville network
no but they're not their content is not
supposed to be exclusively for it's not
in the name white entertainment
television right yeah right it'd be like
no that's that's racist of course why
are you doing that like don't don't
exclude and i don't think when you know
what entertainment television and i
don't care that there's pete my point is
fine
no problem and
just
make make original content you want an
all-female cast make a film that uses an
all-female cast that doesn't want to
have an all black cast make a show that
has no black cast and it can be
successful like blackish like fresh
prince but don't say oh this was too
white oh this was too masculine that's
when you create divide and then on cnn
pitch about the political divide but
it's when you create an unrealistic
force divide i mean that's really the
problem is you go and watch a show like
blackish one of those they're not really
grounded in any kind of reality where
even though it's you know a little over
the top fresh prince was pretty
realistic so his family matters yeah is
that the dad was a cop yeah you know
i loved black shows probably more than
white shows as a kid yeah and my
favorite being in living color and
what's kind of funny is jim carrey
exploded because he was the token on
that show he was also the most talented
probably oh as far as the sketch actor
come on
awesome
is really i mean yeah what you're saying
he well you know what he was so good the
only reason he wasn't on snl is because
al franken hated him right yeah so i
mean he they got lucky jim carrey was a
standout that's what i'm saying
of course yeah he certainly was the best
impressionist and creating bizarre
characters i actually think underrated
in that show was david alan greer i love
david allen grier he's going to detroit
yeah and very i saw him do stand up and
i remember the audience was not laughing
because it's kind of weird and it was
very funny all right let's move on here
yeah it works with him he's a legend
yeah he's great
i've heard he's a
an oddball but a sweet guy he was very
nice yeah yeah a little odd but yeah
i've heard nothing but good things uh
when i met him he was wearing pink pants
huh
i was too
let's just admit that men on film was
one of the funniest things ever just
because of the tiny hats yeah and every
time there was a woman movie they'd just
go hated it
yeah let's do all-male steel magnolias
now that i think about it
thelma and louise let's let's do a
female-centric magnolia tom cruise
respect
the vagina all right
the four people who saw magnolia i know
understand that reference okay so this
is a new poll that came out by the way
from rasmussen turns out that msnbc and
cnn viewers believe that the mortality
rate of covid is five times that of
reality what of course just following
the science folks
how could that be so re uh i have the
numbers here specifically 28 of
democrats think more than 10 of people
diagnosed with covid have died from the
disease and that's 22 of cnn 24 of msnbc
viewers uh only sorry only 22 and 24
correctly estimated the coven mortality
wow so they're both equally terrible
networks almost by now like we've used
them as kind of this like okay they
claim to be centrists but we're going to
go after them it's like they're not as
bad as their channels are canceled right
yeah they should be removed from all
social media as well and i don't know
why this was fit in but the poll also
found that all cnn viewers believe that
a 17 tip is acceptable oh oh bernie
you're welcome
i love he tips 17 might be 18. i want to
be fair can we just start
again real quick yeah can we see that
picture of him please take it in a
little bit it's the best picture
he looks surprised there's a hot dog in
this ice cream cone yeah it looks like
yeah
he's like i thought it was a popsicle
no he got the check and he was like it's
an automatic 20 gratuity on a party over
eight yes he's just shocked when he sees
the extra five cents on the bill
uh you know what hey guys we're going to
go to the donald trump commentating
sports uh let's go to that in between
after this segment on abortion uh he's
going to be commenting in the evander
holly field is he really uh and uh uh
the tour belfort fight dave you can't do
that yeah what are you doing yeah we'll
talk about it we'll talk about a mug
club you can't make eden reese's on the
show yeah i know it's not a sponsorship
plug right now i missed breakfast slater
oh geez that's not breakfast there's a
carb up we'll also need to go through
the food pyramid with yeah so let's look
at the texas abortion law again i
i want to hear before i go through what
the law actually is and contrasting it
with leftist states where when left to
their own devices what kind of laws they
have i i want you to then look at the
contrast and decide allow me to offer
you
allow me to presuppose that places like
colorado and places like virginia are
far more extreme to the left my left
your right uh than texas is yeah to the
right and this happens all across the
country people don't know when people
say most americans are pro-abortion
there's a there's a cut-off well before
the laws
actually have a cut-off in these other
states and that's a big problem with why
we're not having it on a dialogue but
before before we get into it just
comment that's the best thing you can do
with the algorithm i want to know where
a big fan of the texas abortion law or
not um but first we have to go to a clip
of uh talking about governor abbott he's
in a wheelchair oh i didn't know that
aoc
was uh you know she i think they call
this uh a burn right
she did a nice breath she did a nice
burn on the guy in the wheelchair
alexandria here's a clip
rape
is a crime
and texas will work tirelessly to make
sure that we eliminate all rapists from
the streets of texas
what about the homes of texas right
because most rates are not stranger
rates congresswoman alexander that's a
metaphor
phrase governor abbott's comments as
deeply ignorant
well i find governor abbott's comments
disgusting and i think there's twofold
one i don't know if he is familiar with
a menstruating person's body in fact i
do know that he's
and i'm sorry we have to break it down
on you know break down biology 101 oh
biology okay but in case no one has
informed him before in our life in his
life
six weeks pregnant means two weeks late
for your period and two weeks late on
your period for any person any person
with a menstrual cycle that's three
times if you're stressed this is biology
101 changes or for really no reason at
all so you don't have six weeks
this idea that we're going to quote
unquote end rape
when
the same type of frankly rape culture
and the same type of misogynistic
culture that informs you in the
misogynistic culture that lets men's
those
co-op
are held by the governor himself and
this texas state legislature
frankly there are many people in power
as we know from the metoo movement that
commits sexual assault and help their
friends cover up these crimes and some
of them even serve in the same state
legislation that are voting on these
anti uh and you know just these
anti-choice bills it's awful
um okay she knows the way she looks is
why she's anything right
menstruating persons let's be really
clear about that because she said female
she tried because that used to be
allowed because female was biological
right and gender was different
menstruating so let's be really clear
about this when and this is also the
problem with the and we're going to
debunk all the crap that she said in a
second as to why it's untrue but uh
this is this is the superficial nature
of the left right what is menstrual
menstruation is a cycle that happens
with one when you're talking about
ovulation you're talking about this left
okay we can go through this but it's
it's far more than just blood what it is
is actually a sign of fertility and a
sign when you are pregnant it is
actually a part of the cycle that
eventually leads to the miracle of life
they say no no no no it's just about
blood from an orifice because let's be
honest when you're talking about
menstruating persons who aren't
biological females it's it's the
equivalent to the mask and remember the
halloween masks with the that would
you'd hit the pump and it would bleed oh
yeah those are awesome
that's all it is and all i know is if
the kid had that mask his parents must
be rich yeah
full-size candy bars in that house but
it's the same thing just like oh
unrealistic stand with the lgbtq aip
movement it reduces women to something
superficial oh we need to change barbie
we need to have barbie be more realistic
hey what's the woman of the year uh it's
a former man and a corset who is
deliberately creating dimensions like a
barbie
and perpetuates every single superficial
stereotype which we now declare is just
as much of a part of the splendor that
is womanhood
i love that she got like all snooty and
and i known somebody maybe
snotty snooty
good reference that she said that and is
like i can't believe somebody hasn't
told them let's do biology 101 when
females i mean menstruating i mean uh
persons that bleed she had to correct
herself because she knows this is
stupidity and by the way did you see the
lower kind of third that they had for
cnn says that governor abbott will end
rape that's not what he said at all they
played the clip and he said we will work
tirelessly to end rape in texas
shouldn't they be standing up and
applauding right now and by the way
do you know what that means no aoc can't
say that because you know what that
requires it requires a more robust
police force it requires more effective
funding to the police it requires
deporting illegal immigrants and giving
them no quarter it requires not allowing
sanctuary cities that's the only way
that you get rid of rape but instead
they have to line and say well because
most rape is in the house and it's not
it's uh it's not stranger rape look
no
okay i thought
i thought most rapes happen now when you
regret having sex with someone eight
years ago and then you come forward well
denim throws off the bell curve that's
the story first
gorgeous woman
justin also a rapist
yes yes uh uh lies about it she is
one child
yeah not a rapist
self-admitted self-admitted in her book
we're not making any comments right okay
so we're going to debunk all the dumb
stuff that aoc just said uh
but uh possible
it's like shooting googly catfish in a
barrel
[Laughter]
yeah she does have crazy girl eyes she
absolutely does
her eyes are the equivalent to the uh
the the super soaker that could squirt
around corners
what those are great
those are awesome oh my gosh i just had
the one with like the extra ball in the
back with like a another pack of water
and you were like never sound like that
no no no this was you yeah like i'm
gonna get and then dave would be like oh
i'm wet oh what yeah yeah we do it all
the time yeah all right so uh aoc is not
the only leftist here by the way to lose
her mind at the thought of babies uh not
being killed not being let's be clear
chopped apart limb from limb then head
and sucked down a tube and thrown into
the trash from their mother's womb she's
not the only one absolutely uh uh
furious over this idea
so
what this law is really about is not
stopping abortions across the board
this is about bearing down on the most
vulnerable among us one of the points
the very daniel
of this law is to chill people not just
abortion providers in texas but to chill
the entire community of people who want
to help women right now into second
guessing whether they're going to be on
the hook and that was the purpose of the
law that was the law the supreme court
let go into effect you don't have to
worry about it against abortion
um
strong
i think that it is morally wrong it's
against my faith yes
but i agree with you whoopi in the sense
that i see this incredible hypocrisy
coming from the christian right here we
go
amongst especially people like myself
red herring coming to say that abortion
is wrong
and say it's about the sanctity of life
three yeah they're so supportive of gun
ownership there it is they're so
supportive of ar-15s they're so
supportive of the death penalty
yeah it's completely inconsistent for
human beings to believe that a convicted
murderer or rapist there's that word
again should be penalized for his crimes
while believing that an innocent uh a
crimeless baby deserves to live hey by
the way how do you get rid of rapists
no death penalties and no house will
have a firearm yeah it's entirely
consistent to say we're going to do away
with rapists because we want harsher
punishment we want to discourage crime
and of course in texas we want
law-abiding citizens to be able to own
their own firearms to protect their own
life liberty pursuit of happiness as
well as children in the home it is so
this is the argument from the left look
let me make sure that you guys
understand this because we've done
changed my minds on this and i don't
want you to get tripped up they say oh
are you pro-life and you know what's
coming is then are you pro insert any
free government program here if you're
pro-life you should support more school
funding if you're pro-life you should
support two years maternity slash
paternity slash bleeding persons leave
if you're pro-life and they go through a
list
no no pro-life means the right to life
it doesn't mean the right to force
someone else at gunpoint to pay for
services that you want let's be really
clear about that it's a weak argument i
i can't believe that anyone still uses
it and even more i just don't want
anyone there to be tripped up on it now
really but it is it's just taking two
issues and making them one thing that's
not what it's about you can't be
pro-life and protect your wife's life
with a firearm well i'm curious is there
i don't know if there's a stat on this
but do we know how many women have been
raped that have been walking down the
street with an ar-15 slung over their
shoulder i'm betting it's low yeah yeah
it's gonna be probably right
so much i'm like unless it was just a
replica for their remake yeah well
that's true she could have just been
going onto the set of saving private
sandra
that would have been an m1 i believe
saving captain and it was an m16 in
vietnam it was not an ar-15 get your gun
that's right true well i'm sorry that's
what's important here it was just for
the joke no
can't allow it because then sonny from
the view is going to be wrong he said
that's a nice thing
yeah are you a natural blonde sonny so
why is that not co-op that's just me
what we're talking about like you know
remember they had a problem with white
people getting cornrows which by the way
is any girl who went on a cruise and
came back with those shitty little beads
in their hair pardon my language but for
some reason like i had beyonce straight
blonde hair oh i don't care i just find
it funny so the heartbeat part of this
bill let me really clear is great and i
don't just mean great because i'm
pro-life i mean it's a very consistent
way to draw a line yeah this is the
issue uh that it comes down to when
people say well this amount of time look
where does life begin now i believe that
life begins at fertilization some people
say conception i think fertilization is
maybe a more accurate term let's not get
caught on this however i do think it's
undeniable when you were talking about a
separate heartbeat when someone says
that's my body that's a separate
heartbeat a separate organ that's a
consistent line to
raw let's be clear about that and they
say well most sorry go ahead what you're
doing what's to say it's not a clump of
cells that's the argument that they will
always use it is very small but i i've
had experience with this i've written
that sonogram yeah yeah moment well up
to eight months is just it's absurd i i
can't even understand i mean i know you
have i know ladies you have some trouble
sometimes picking a restaurant but this
seems like something you should make a
choice on
way earlier yeah then by the time it's
like well up until it can speak well and
that's important to know when people say
this is an extreme bill yeah look at the
the suing the litigation components of
it good lord
this is the only time i've ever
supported a double mask quarterback
and we know it's a problem because his
demographic is vaccine hesitant
most of him isn't
it doesn't matter it's just like the
delta variant may pierce through anyway
let's be really clear to you people say
that i can't believe this is an
infringement on women's rights look most
people think that they are
pro-abortionist country that's true
there are stats that show they believe
in in a term like choice yeah women now
of course democrats don't believe in
your right to choose when it comes to
what car you can drive what kind of
taxes you can pay or even if you can
drink a big gulp uh what kind of school
you can send your kids to literally they
are against the term school choice the
term offends them but they're pro-choice
when it comes to abortion
but most americans don't know what
abortion is don't know what it looks
like and don't know what the laws are
in states where they have had the right
uh completely unfettered to abortion so
let's be really clear do you think that
six weeks is and i really do want to
hear from you on this yeah do you
believe that six weeks meaning heartbeat
okay there is now a new heartbeat so
we're not even at the point of
conception fertilization which is what
pro-lifers believe
uh and science shows that's when new dna
is formed but we were talking about a
separate set of a separate heart at that
point do you believe that is more
extreme
and more inconsistent than states like
we will go through virginia colorado
where you can have abortions up until
and including birth now when we're
talking about virginia you don't have to
take my word for it here is uh uh
governor ralph northam at the time
talking about
abortion performed after birth on camera
there are you know when we talk about
third trimester abortions these are done
uh with the consent of obviously the the
mother with the consent
of the physicians more than one
physician by the way
and it's done in cases where there may
be severe deformities there may be a
fetus that's non-viable so in this
particular example uh if a mother is in
labor i can tell you exactly what would
happen
the infant would be delivered
the infant would be kept comfortable
the infant would be resuscitated if if
that's what the mother and the family
desired and then a discussion would
ensue between the physicians and the
mothers okay so
oh my god let me be clear about
something here of course i am condemning
any type of extremist violence and of
course we think it's a horrible thing
when you have when you have people who
go out there and bomb clinics that being
said right the amount of times that this
has happened
you can count on one hand when you're
talking about abortion clinics you know
shootings bombings right
condemning it
but again just like we've talked about
now how you when you vilify young white
males for something that they haven't
done the danger here is when you have
someone like that who's a governor in a
position of authority
saying that this is common practice in
law that we will deliver a baby and keep
it comfortable until we kill it look
do you do you not understand how that's
going to have a cause and effect with
someone i have to go save these babies
that are actually being delivered at
that point it's no longer a question if
he feels like he's going in and saving a
life he may feel like he has to go in
and save a life
we're not talking about a zygote yeah do
you not understand that these law the
danger that these laws present when they
are so extreme by the way out of touch
with nearly all american voters yeah
when you hear what he said too we're
going to resuscitate yeah if that's what
they want us to do and then have a
conversation yeah if you can give it
mouth-to-mouth it's not a cluster of
cells no
i i it's just this is one of the most
despicable things this is it's killing a
baby i mean at that point that doesn't
make any sense and that's the law
as compared to texas i mean you get it
no it's no of course you get a six week
cut off it's like oh once there's a
heartbeat there's a cutoff but i may not
know i'm pregnant though oh check okay
if so here's what we're saying you're
going on mtv yeah your argument your
argument aoc is that people don't always
know when they're pregnant okay look how
about this all we're saying is that you
can avoid killing a child we're going to
ask you to test a little bit more
regularly if you are having sex
that's it well that's the goal so
inconvenient it went from safe legal and
rare to on-demand uh taxpayer-funded
period and it went to you're damaging
you're putting women's health in danger
and now well i may not know i'm pregnant
i'm sorry do you really just want to
live your life with no accountability or
responsibility miss menstruating person
ally okay he on a stick yeah
it'll tell you they'll
it
burns well cranberry juice i recommend
um in colorado too this is something
because people will say well you're just
taking that out of context no go read
the laws in colorado and we we'll have
the link in the description by the way
all references are available all sources
are available in the description at
loudwritecredit.com we went and did an
undercover video of abortion clinics
which some people try to say was edited
out of context nope and i but
we've always uploaded footage there on
mug club we're just not going to upload
three four hours of stuff and random
time codes nope
go ahead file
file any shoot you want to say it's
edited out of context i'll wait so we
went there undercover at an abortion
clinic to show people what abortion is
actually like and uh the women who are
working with us ran into this lady
who was
um about to have in it so this happened
in colorado have an abortion at 32 weeks
that's eight months yeah we did this i
believe about a year and a half ago
here's the clip meet we'll call her
patient x
how far along are you i'm 28.
and as we later found out it was
actually worse to get your ultrasound
yeah i mean i got further along
kind of get his big head or whatever
you're like putting me in 32 weeks
that's right just like thousands every
day across the country this woman was
going to end her 32 week that's eight
months her eight month old baby's life
and just to be clear uh and just because
i want to rub salt
in the demonic satanic death cult that
has modern leftist wounds uh because of
the ladies who were undercover who
followed up that woman did not have that
abortion that baby is alive today
literally saves someone's life
i can't belie and i know what you're
thinking honestly that's cruel that's
cruel no there was no pressure you know
what happened the lady who worked who
went there undercover just said hey i
believe just sent a picture this is what
the baby is at 32 weeks yeah didn't have
the abortion i consider that wonderful
because you know eight months i just had
twins who were eight and a half months
yeah this is an issue to me and we've
talked about and i i don't dave is more
i think you like you're like a lot of
americans who think they're pro-choice
and then when you understand the reality
of the laws and what it's like people go
i have to re-evaluate this here a little
bit i will say i've always been pro-life
so i sort of went the opposite direction
and that a lot of people think they're
pro-choice and they have a baby and then
most of them become pro-life because
they have this emotional attachment i
was always pro-life logically but now
that i've had twins um and i've spent
time with these babies uh i find that
emotionally any story that you hear
about the holocaust or any film where
there's abuse of a baby just really
makes me sick to my stomach i always
thought it was morally wrong so
logically and my principles have always
been consistent but now there is this
visceral reaction because i'm replacing
that baby with my baby's face and so i
honestly
cannot picture when you have people who
um
have children at this point who are
parents who've gone through that process
particularly parents who've had babies
born prematurely which by the way occurs
far earlier than eight months all the
time all across this country and they
still support abortion i i can't see
that as anything other than evil yeah
and it's bred from something that's just
completely lazy yeah are you telling me
that you can't have protection oh it's
not 100 oh but i mean i'm just talking
about the late term abortion which is
legal in all of these states but
sometimes when a young kid is throwing a
tantrum you're like
yeah yeah
i mean well here's the idea of like i'm
going to aspen
[Laughter]
that john denver's full anyway so
but what i think at least for my own
personal view besides rape and incest
obviously which is just my own personal
opinion i understand that um
the idea that it has to be this crazy
extreme where we're fighting against
eight months whatever it might be a lot
of the times when they do outlaw
something it does bring in that criminal
element not that they do it safely not
that what it is isn't disgusting but
then you end up losing two lives because
you have now a mother with an infection
they're doing these back alley abortions
i think that's the dangerous element of
it oh i i understand that too but i
think that any abortion is is dangerous
because you're ending a life and i think
that like yeah like they're not that
they're not that
that safe and in other words people
picture abortion to be look you're
chopping off arms
legs
head right and you're just like you ever
cut a you ever cut a sanui steak i'm
sorry if you have children here i want
to be very close just this morning
there's there's there's you're talking
about spinal cord you're talking about
tissue this is not a simple snip snip
here a couple of la dee da this is a
rough procedure no matter what but i
understand your point i think a lot of
americans under the guise say okay well
we need to allow early on abortions but
again if you show most americans what
the laws are in texas it was 20
something weeks by the way well that's
insane i mean and the idea that this
woman who wasn't even aware of what a
baby looked like at eight months i mean
i hope that kid's not homeschooled but i
mean eight eight months in that's that
to me that's just killing something it
doesn't make any sense to do that yeah
and this is this is why you cannot
negotiate this is why
what you would say uh is extremist this
is what creates sort of absolu i guess
the absolute morality that you ooh try
and avoid right aoc is people go well
why should i concede any territory with
you you're saying six weeks we we
conceded some territory instead of
conception fertilization we said a
heartbeat you say up until and including
birth so no
no compromise no reach across the aisle
screw bipartisanship that's what happens
let's ask you let's put let's put the
ball on your court okay
what is safe
reasonable
uh as it relates to abortion laws yeah
genuinely people out there people out
there if you're pro-choice if you're
watching this and you're pro-choice let
me know what do you think is the
reasonable cutoff i just don't see a
logically consistent one outside of uh
outside of fertilization but i can
understand the argument legally that
okay we do a heartbeat bill i think
that's a totally reasonable place let's
go through some of the specific claims
and then you guys just jump in i know
gerald you have a few points here that
are usually this is a topic that's in
your wheelhouse uh so one claim of
course that we just were talking about
but aoc made and someone else here makes
oh i know who it is is that women don't
even know that they're pregnant by this
point and you don't even know you're
pregnant before the six weeks i never
found out about any of my babies before
i was six weeks so i would never
were you planning on getting an abortion
well it also depends on how large you
are before you're pregnant
oh well i don't think you start you
don't start growing for a little while
not my point but if you're in a constant
state of feeling bloated
well that's true but well and you know
there's other clues that something could
have happened right yeah like
unprotected
that's not true though let's be really
clear according to the american
pregnancy uh agency most women find out
they're pregnant during weeks four
through seven okay now they haven't
measured just saying oh six so in other
words there's a good way to find out
before this and if a woman is trying to
get pregnant they know significantly
before then and if a woman is having sex
engaging in sexual activity that could
result in pregnancy i don't think that
it's too much to ask for a woman to be
responsible to do some checks yeah
absolutely and you know i mean there's a
limited window for when you can get
pregnant like it is truly a miracle when
these things happen i know couples and
friends who have tried
for months and months and months and
months and not been successful at this
and so it's not like we're talking like
you can just have sex any time during
the month and that's going to happen
right so it is a limited window and all
we're saying is take some personal
responsibility and just check that's it
if you had sex last night check in a few
days you know i don't know exactly
personal responsibility maybe take a
week see what happens people pee on a
stick a couple of times and you don't
have to buy like the fancy
sucks dave you test all the time for
this stuff it's always negative i'm just
gonna tell you yeah can't have a kid oh
well i feel that it's important come on
look as our token menstruating person
let him have it
let him have this win
until he chops it off i'm not giving him
a name i am not going to stop wearing
butt ponds
oh that's all we're asking just just
check yeah you know it's like oh they're
gonna have to go to they're gonna have
to go to mexico to get their abortions
performed or or or just go with me here
um if you're engaging in sexual activity
yeah mischievously just be responsible
well the sex education system no no no
no no no i understand that but you fail
to understand the argument doesn't work
because it's 2021.
you could also check the calendar you
could also get on an airplane and go to
a place where it's perfectly acceptable
as opposed to i don't know having a
coyote take you into it well that's
controversial yeah i i want to have a
coyote but
but the arguments back that's just it's
stupid yeah somebody nobody's running
what's the hundred pack of there's
testing strips don't do like the uh the
the nice brands in the store it's a
testing strip somebody look it up you
can buy them by like a hundred pack to
be able to test and see if you're
pregnant and they're super cheap they're
at the dollar store yeah yeah
you know what maybe spring for the two
dollar streets yeah you might want to
buy three or four at the dollar yeah
because i've been pregnant many times
just you might get just do it when
you're doing your fat diet uh keto
testing strips yeah just pee in another
stick between your bacon and eggs
so another another misconception here
about the abortion restrictions is that
they would cause women with
life-threatening conditions to die
rather than get treatment talked about
that's wrong the texas law there's a
provision uh in the scenario where there
are life-threatening cases against the
mother um and they're onerous it means
the doctor actually just has to write
down that there's a life-threatening
situation documented oh dear lord well
also it seems like there are quite a few
caveats here when the uh international
or the national claim is that they've
completely outlawed abortion 100 yeah
it's once there's a heartbeat outside of
scenarios where it could threaten the
life of the mother and those scenarios
can be very broadly interpreted
let's be really clear about that oh the
humanity have you ever considered
abortion up until and after birth like
our states yeah no
we just need to do abortions i
personally think should be a midlife
evaluation around 35.
we just sit you down and go ah
we'll take a vote so like china yes yeah
that's how they do it but they don't
really evaluate unless you're a gymnast
then they just you know they send you
out back at 16 years old let's say yeah
your career over it's much earlier all
right for my old
they send you to michigan state yes
that's terrible come on
you almost you almost 14 can't be in
this game forever
hurry up for those who say it's racist
they sent nine-year-olds into the
olympics and gymnastics okay that was a
scandal a few years ago but her memories
are so short-term he's just doing uh
he's just doing a chinese accent you're
right i did now they're all flexible
people they are very flexible people um
i guess i don't know why so finally uh
they're also claiming um this is a claim
and this is where we'll get into some of
my issues that i do have with the
abortion law that uh women can be sued
now the claim is wrong right but there
are issues i think with some of sort of
the
litigious nature i should say of this
bill but the claim that the left is
making which is absolutely incorrect is
that women can be sued for having an
abortion here you go what grounds julia
help me i don't i don't get this like
maybe i'm misunderstanding it this
actually lets private citizens say
nothing who have zero connection to the
person getting an abortion take legal
action
how does this happen
why
that's right it means someone with no
connection at all could be able to get
ten thousand dollars just as we just
pointed out nope
so look let's be really clever
incorrect the beak on that gail yes stop
it
it's a real woodpecker
so um the ability to sue specifically
applies to and this is something really
clearly though you want to arrest a
woman who have abortions i i truly
believe that that
most women who have abortions out there
are lied to they don't really know what
they're doing and when you actually see
women who've had abortions performed and
then they have they go through the
process of giving birth and having a
child
most of the time they say oh i i
couldn't believe what i was doing and
they even they become pro-life
statistically they are more likely to
become pro-life once they've had babies
even if they've had abortions before
that because they didn't really know
what was happening my problem has always
been with the abortion
providers yeah people who sorry about
stuff i said they were they've been lied
to their entire life right i think it's
a clump of cells and it's no big deal
and then they have a kid they're like
holy crap i tracked this thing as it was
growing it's the size of a grape now now
it's the size of a pear now it's the
size of a grapefruit now and you track
the life of this kid that's living
inside of you and you're like what the
hell did i do by the way i think you're
i don't want to speak over my children
comparing them to a fruit well we do
that all the time it's like it's just i
know but it's a problem reference then
you're born with a little uh you're born
with a little bro i don't want a little
bruce valanche no what about a little
cootie
bruce berlin
once he was a little cootie and then he
was a grapefruit and now he's just a
full-grown fruit i'm glad they had me
guys
i think uh bruce valance is just michael
moore he just tosses on a wig
[Laughter]
so the ability to sue just like we've
talked specifically applies to the
person performing the abortion to the
doctor performing the abortion not the
woman this is also a common red hearing
from the left so you want to jail a
woman who've had abortions no that's not
what we're talking about and certainly
no one is arguing that we retroactively
jail any woman who's had an abortion in
the past that is not true these
conversations that are taking place
right now are not accurate they are not
true now that being said um
there are some problems with the bill
yeah and one of the reasons that they
put that provision in the bill was it's
the only enforcement mechanism right if
you read the bill it actually says right
before the the fine the civil penalty of
ten thousand dollars that can be awarded
to somebody who sues them
uh and and and gets found out that
they're right okay yeah you did perform
from the abortion or yeah right um is
also just actions to stop it right so
that's i that's a little bro it should
be noted by the way before you continue
uh in this bill they actually went out
of their way to make sure that uh
rapists uh are prevented from suing
women they impregnate from having an
abortion because that has happened in
the past there you go because basically
it becomes sort of a custody issue with
rapists this is not unprecedented by the
way and they made sure again because of
the harsh policy on rape yeah well and
so here dave and i'll kind of address
your point that you brought up just a
minute ago and that we've talked about i
understand the the hesitancy around rape
and incest but let's just follow this
through so if a woman is raped and she
becomes pregnant you're telling me that
the logical thing to do is to then kill
a child because of it i understand that
it's much more complicated than that so
i'm not trying to simplify it too much
but i'm just saying that this is the
brass tax this is what you get down to
at the end of the day if you end up
pregnant after being raped
you're telling me that the the moral
just thing to do is to kill
a child respectfully i'm just going to
say i think that's the wrong argument to
make uh
interesting yeah i think there are two
arguments to make because i've done this
there are two they're really i'll i'll
give you one
and then i'll give you the one that's
actually the quickest path toward
cutting it off okay this is something
that i hope you p if you're watching
right now use this when you get into
these conversations so one is when they
say so you're going to force a woman to
carry the pregnancy from rape princess
just say no i'm not forcing her to do
anything
i'm forbidding her from
responding to an act of evil with an
even greater act of evil i'm not forcing
anyone to carry anything you're gonna
afford then they use that same argument
with uh any type of pregnancy you're
gonna force a woman to carry no i'm not
well so then you're you're you just want
women no i'm i'm pro four options i'm
pro
abstinence contraception motherhood
adoption i'm just not pro the fifth
option which is murder okay but before
we get to that when they say what about
rape and incest okay um look let's have
this conversation if we allow all
abortions for rape incest threat of the
mother and that's it no other abortions
would you be okay with it no then shut
up right then shut up just like when you
say what about the children with the
dreamers well hold on a second
can we can we get rid of illegal
immigrants who are crowding our prisons
and here in sanctuary city no okay then
don't tell me about the child it's it's
a non-issue right yeah that's just the
argument no that's the best argument to
kind of cut it off because you're right
they're they're not really willing you
are you know and you are you i i would
agree with you on that 100 i just think
when it comes down to that as its own
separate issue for yourself
if you're raped i don't think you should
be
i don't think you should be forced to
carry that child i think that that is up
to you i think that that can have
extreme emotional damage to force
somebody to oh yeah i agree i mean i
think i think rape causes emotional
damage yeah and and incest i mean come
on
yeah we've all
done it but i don't think we should
come on later
we would be without no but that's kind
of my point is like do you want another
lena dunham we don't want much more
arctic saw than we have okay
west virginia no but again but
it only comes down to where does is it a
life and my point is if we're talking
about rape or incest
then either way at that point
we are still talking about a separate
heartbeat and you are ending a life you
are stopping the heart and it's not your
own heart when someone says well it's
actually my body oh do you have two
hearts yeah
are you one of those i forget that
someone can tell me what fish is it that
has two hearts they need a beer after it
uh there's a fish with two hearts in
lake michigan i know what you're talking
about don't elephants have two anyway i
digress the point is you're not
some of the girls have been with
some of them some of them bell's too
hard at ale yeah i know but i don't know
it's not the the fish the fish the thing
is the point is
i probably do because i'm just so caring
because you're just so caring oh
i'm sorry anyway this is the no this
brings me to a point that i disagree
with no i'm not saying for you um i i
don't think that this lawsuit provision
is good no uh for example it could
potentially allow uber drivers to be
sued if they take a woman to
an abortion and they could be sued by
someone who wasn't involved with this
abortion
if you look at i think it's pretty hard
for someone to consistently argue for
effectively like tort reform when we're
talking about reducing health care costs
and then and i'm not talking about look
if someone performs an abortion and it's
against the law after six weeks that
person needs to be held accountable yeah
but i don't want our court systems
packed with a bunch of people who are
effectively trying to pocket ten
thousand dollars because they suspect
someone being guilty of being involved
in an abortion not only that but i think
this may make this law something that
could be i would hate to see it tossed
out entirely right because of a portion
that i do see as legally a problem so i
wish they hadn't gone that broad with it
right doesn't change the fact that the
left is lying no woman can be sued for
having an abortion right they need to
clarify this part and just say look
we're talking about the people who are
performing the abortions we're talking i
don't i don't think if a mom and dad
have a crying 16 year old in their
in their den that if they pay for an
abortion that they should be sued and
you know ten thousand dollars could be
awarded or the uber driver like you said
uh those that's not part of the problem
that we're really trying to address and
so if they could just come back and
clarify that then they could they could
kind of ward off this challenge because
it wouldn't or judge reinhardt stop
beating the reese's again dave what are
you doing dave stepping into reese's
that's enough that's rude hey bye bye
messi by the way before we move on hey
hit the notification bell if you're
watching it you know hit the uh what's
the no yeah the notification uh uh not
the subscription button the notification
you gotta hit the bell icons don't mean
anything right
notifications tune in every day live we
stream to you there's without a net
monday through thursday 10 a.m free ball
10 a.m eastern uh they were just talking
about it on uh on uh on cnn they said oh
uh i think was it did they say mansion
wanted to put a pause on 3.5
trillion spending though pelosi didn't
uh agree with mitch and putting oh
pelosi but the point is when we're
talking about oh maybe we should put a
pause on the 3.5 trillion dollar
spending bill you think the founding
fathers would have had any time for this
[ __ ] this is just the fact that we're
we're just considering these a rounding
error do you have any idea how much
money is being spent do you have any
idea how cheap cash is and how little it
will be worth yeah in the amount of time
we're just talking about printing and
spending like
we're so desensitized to this yeah this
is on top of all the other spending by
the way so don't be like oh well this is
the only thing we're doing three and a
half trillion for our economy size
that's not so bad we're backed by
nothing that doesn't seem to bother me
the whole thing's full faith and credit
dave but everything is pretend dogecoin
none of
that's a that's a lamborghini 225 yeah i
want to hang on to that
only we're talking about we're only
we're talking about trillions
trillion is that a mundane detail
michael so uh we'll have to do woke
military tomorrow because but i think we
another story we have donald trump oh
right donald trump is actually going to
be uh so uh uh choice house you'll need
to bring us up the story first donald
trump is going to be
commentating the evander hollyfield the
tour belfor fight huh this isn't a bit
this is a bit donald trump and i believe
donald trump jr are going to actually be
commentating
it's both of them yeah that's going to
be all the boxing match between evander
hollyfield and former uh middleweight
champion in in mixed martial arts vitor
belfort
somebody just sold me a paper that
sounds insane
we gotta watch that this is yeah it says
this is you can go again all references
available louder with crowder.com people
think this is not true and it's the
triller thing which was the show i
talked about where they had megan the
stallion oh no not megan italian who was
it dogia whatever humping the floor
first 19 minutes
oh gosh but this is not the first people
don't realize this so you think that
it's a bit this is not the first time i
mean donald trump's been involved with
combat sports for a while some of the
early uh ufc events were at trump world
wrestling wrestling progression yeah
brought against loving us right now but
he's also provided commentary to sports
internationally uh for a good long while
yeah
okay
we're playing cricket
and he's about to bat wait that's not
regulation that's a cork bat rigged
red
and he was that other head like a [ __ ]
oh this is
boring how long did this game go
four days
i won michigan
wow he's a talented man
in four days yeah
it's a multi-faceted jerry lewis had
some solid opinions on cricket go ahead
and google it in your office
we can't even play that jerry lewis clip
anymore where he called the kid an
illiterate
illiterate forbidden from matt damon's
mouth word yes i would use a vpn or
maybe incognito mode and then
then catches himself live on television
oh let's show let's uh pull that guys up
let's pull that up uh for mug club so
people if you're not a member of my club
enter in the promo code crowd or come
back what do they get they get ten
dollars i think it's twenty dollars off
twenty dollars off uh and we're going to
show the jerry lewis clip there you go
and
all you folks at the media matters and
all the critics who actually have
multiple memberships we thank you for
your support yeah
yeah
how do you like your mug i love that
people who exist to write hit pieces on
the show have had to pay money i know
it's fantastic and the debate isn't even
getting their money back oh this son of
a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he's damn entertaining we're gonna red
kill you soon don't worry yeah before we
move on uh tomorrow we'll talk about the
woke military the guy who had to resign
because he questioned the leadership in
the afghanistan withdrawal as opposed to
the angry lesbian who criticizes her
former troops uh and blatantly breaks
military protocol think about the medal
of honor not sure maybe purple heart
what um
yeah jane yeah rainbow heart but before
we go to that this is something we need
to talk about okay so uh remember the
whole
doc dr fauci doctor let's be clear about
this uh there was nih funding to the
wuhan lab right uh now uh there have
been well let me let me remind you
because this is what the media moves on
from and i've been watching cnn all
morning they have not covered the story
this is
huge talk about gaslighting right they
wanted everyone to believe that you were
a crazy conspiracy theorist if you
thought
that this came potentially from a lab as
opposed to nature which
by the way remember like no one's talked
about that yeah since the john stewart
issue they just want to move away just
like they want you all to think that
you're a conspiracy theorist if you
understand that seven i believe it's 75
of americans have at least received one
dose of the vaccine and we still have
surging cases uh and the delta variant
is a predominant strain
they want you to believe that you are a
conspiracy theorist if you say well hold
on a second does that mean that there
are breakthrough cases well those
haven't really been monitored unless
you've been hospitalized or killed they
want you to think it's a conspiracy
theory that this was created in a lab
and they want you to think that it's a
conspiracy theory that there could be
any effective treatments available for
anyone who has covet including if your
doctor prescribes it and if you wonder
about the efficacy uh of any treatment
that insert whatever here with the delta
variant they want you always to think
that you are absolutely crazy so that's
why they aren't covering this story so
let me remind you of what we covered not
long ago rand paul was on this like a
dog on a bone
asking dr fauci when he testified before
congress whether the nih ever funded
gain of function research there at the
wilhelm lab dr fauci knowing that it is
a crime to lie to congress do you wish
to retract your statement of may 11
where you claimed that the nih never
funded gain of function research in
wuhan
senator paul i have never lied
before the congress and i do not retract
that statement
this paper that you were referring to
was judged by qualified staff up and
down the chain
as not
being gained a function
let me finish take an animal virus and
you increase this responsibility to
humans right you're saying that's not
gain a function yeah that is correct and
and senator paul you do not know what
you are talking about quite frankly and
i want to say that he's been watching
girlfriends you do not know what you are
talking about
there
you do not know listen listen talk to
the hand because the face doesn't have
ears yes
i'm sorry what what
i'm a doctor this is real life this
ain't no family matters
what are you saying it's just i'm not
the jeffersons you're just trying trying
to
what is that oh that's almost racist i
don't look like woody allen banked paul
simon
and i do not have a little marionette
that lies
so
the evidence
that he lied to congress is mounting now
i've always been very careful to say uh
inaccurate no lied
uh because yesterday the intercept
reported it obtained more than 900
documents regarding ecohealth alliance
the foundation that was given a 3.1
million grant from the nih uh used
partially to identify alter bat
coronaviruses
likely to infect humans that's kind of a
big deal you know what if you give me
3.1 million i promise not to make a
deadly virus yes i promise that's money
well spent isn't it
oh you're listening carnegie music hall
whatever it is yeah yes
yeah you know who's the head of the eco
health systems labs things whatever we
just said it was the peter zorkit i
can't peter jose no zachary jose do you
know jack do you know who was put in
charge of the investigation to find out
if there was gain of function research
done by the wh rhymes with reader dozek
yes look at that oh we've caught the
arsonist let's ask him if he's hey can
you investigate the fire and please tell
us if you started it yeah are you
serious i know it's not me it's like
going down to the walgreens where it's
on fire out there in ferguson like hey
man did you do that i didn't do nothing
man good enough for me all right move on
you hurt him i'm sorry well it gets
worse because in 2019 he actually wrote
for an additional grant to get more
money for uh being able to kind of
deploy resources to take care of an
outbreak if it were to happen in 2019 uh
predominantly in asia yeah if it were in
june of 2019 it's something i'll say
next time in congress like we were only
studying if it were to happen okay and
i'm not saying that it would
i'm not saying that's likely i'm not
saying that i wanted it to happen i'm
just saying we were making sure if it
could be humanly possible well listen dr
fauci hey
talk to the eyebrows
what
what
okay so there's a a rutgers university
chemistry i hate him so much it sucks a
rutgers university chemistry and
chemical biology professor richard uh i
hope i'm pronouncing this right i've
only read it not heard it pronounced
ebright you got doors
this one
um who was quoted in the intercept
article concluded on twitter that quote
these documents make it clear that
assertions by the nih director francis
collins and the niaid director anthony
fauci that the nih did not support gain
of function research or potential
pandemic pathogen enhancement wiv are
untruthful that would be lies is the
word there yeah
you say untruthful i say tomato
[Applause]
now i bet he says tomato yeah he really
does yeah he seems like that and he's
the kind of guy who every time you're
having like a caprese he's like you know
that's actually a fruit
oh yeah i do
it's because of the stems and the seeds
and have you you haven't spent enough
time in the lockers have you anthony
it's like i barely spend any time in a
lab yeah
but i like wearing a leather coat yeah
you like it it makes me feel important
so let's remember do you remember
fauci's email to the deputy director of
nid it was a hugh what was it hugh alken
klaus i don't know the attack we have
the source here uh the attachment red
nature medicine sars gain and function
pdf
[Laughter]
game of function it's the title of it
it's not the sign of the pdf and it's in
the whole purpose to a pdf
as opposed to say like a google doc or
word is that it can't be edited it's the
digital version oh wow how about sharpie
if he was just wearing a gain of
function sweater he doesn't look like a
bigger liar
just has a just has an arrow i'm with
gain of function
it just makes common sense this is all
references are available at
louderwithcrowder.com
the attachment once again
nature medicine sar dash
looks like an m dash
stars gain of function dot pdf it's like
hillary clinton naming it you're gonna
want to delete this
[Laughter]
spirit cooking but tell them that it
didn't happen pdf pdf now in that email
with the gain of function pdf title in
that email it read hugh it is essential
that we speak this am keep your cell
phone on i have a conference call at 7
45 a.m with health and human services
secretary alex azar it is it likely will
be over at 8 45 a.m read this paper i
assume the gain of function pdf
as well as the email that i will forward
to you now you will have tasks today
that must be done
thanks tony
to which i'll concl tony they're in the
first thing replied
he replied to the email with the
attachment king of function pdf
the paper you sent me
gain a function feature performance
specifically the paper you sent me
says
the experiments were performed before
the gain of function pause but have
since been reviewed and approved by nih
not sure what that means since emily is
sure that no coronavirus work has gone
through the p3 framework she will try to
determine if we have any distant ties to
this work abroad so even people there
are confu probably because they as maybe
they weren't in on it they assumed that
they weren't doing gain and function and
like well we wouldn't gosh it's on the
pdf well i mean it's on the title john
gotti once said never put anything in
writing that you don't want read back to
you in court he would be a better health
czar yeah than fouchy no this is like
the o.j simpson school of if i did it
yeah
yeah yeah like what he's gonna once he's
brought before the court instead of not
fitting a glove there's gonna bring out
a laptop he's like i don't know where
are the keys
i couldn't title a pdf i don't know how
to do it i don't know my thumb from my
dick i'm an idiot you gotta right click
it change name don't worry i put it in
an email no one will find
it should have been like the not gain of
[ __ ] by the way if you need my my
email password it's password
h12345
i got it from spaceballs
i figured that it's so obvious it's not
obvious
kind of like when i called the gain of
function
okay to function pdf
it's so obvious that people going
through my hard drives will go right
past it
if they type in gain a function it's not
going to actually come in the header of
several emails
wow
what an idiot
it's unreal
i know
how is this life
like at least at least the abortionists
call it choice just give it something
else
call it like experimental novel virus
that would never affect human research
anything
just don't put gain of function in there
fauci oh my god but this also just goes
to show when people talk about the deep
state when people talk about people in
the swamp what we're talking about are
of course ruling class politicians and
even more concerning than politicians
people understand are people like the
fouchies people like people like
lobbyists people who are in positions of
authority who were never elected to
those positions are accountable to no
one and have been in those positions for
decades that's a problem with fauci
that's why you can have someone like
fauci saying don't take ivermectin it's
toxic didn't you didn't you recommend
azt which by the way not saying that you
shouldn't be able a decision shouldn't
be made for any of these between their
physician and a person but this is why
because there's such a lack of concern
for accountability because fauci has
lived in a world
for decades where he was wrong about
nearly everything is it related to aids
he was wrong about nearly everything is
related to masks early on don't wear
them then wear them he was wrong about
the fact that a vaccine wouldn't be done
within time he was he's been wrong about
so much but they never fear actually
being called to the mat because
cnn won't do it abc nbc cbs and then
they just dismiss fox news or programs
like this as conspiratorial because no
one will cover that gain of function was
in the pdf
the documents also include details this
is something that surprised me again
there's a 900 page 900 pages are
available on the website uh experiments
on humanized mice
conducted at a biosafety level three lab
at the wuhan university center for
animal uh experiment so not i want to be
clear not at the wuhan institute of
virality virology humanized mice
didn't someone else say that and i think
he got kicked off social media 20 years
ago they had cows that produced human
milk 20 years ago they had spiders that
produced body armor spider goats okay
they have human animal hybrids 30 years
ago they've got giant human tissue farms
yeah i guess nobody listened just only
because
i'll be honest with you
i'm kind of [ __ ]
not quite as self-inflicted a gunshot
wound as gain of function pdf that's
true that's true very true
don't look here still dot yeah humanized
i want to make sure you have this right
you'll have human eyes humanized mice
okay dude most of what alex has said has
come true
oh that's not a good thing he's either
absolutely out of his mind or he's
almost nostradamus it seems like i know
i like ali i love stanford
i'm gonna be honest because so many
things that he has said have at least
been partially true yeah every time i
see a frog now i look to see its
mannerism yeah
you got a little you're like this frog's
got a real limb
he's hopping in white in light loafers
[Laughter]
oh you're gonna you're gonna scuff the
lily pads
should have known better than to wear
loafers he talks like a robin williams
impression
oh look big lily pad oh look look
lollipop looks like tits i'm not
interested i'm scared of them
so my point here is fauci
fauci uh uh there's this is a different
and we're going to go to mug club here
in a little bit but have you guys really
thought about this for a second there
are thousands of people
in government in positions of authority
and people who people who have positions
of influence in government who have
never been elected yeah who can't be
recalled
who don't need to face some kind of
reelection so and this also brings up
the poem people say well you know these
politicians are just always campaigning
and i do think there's a problem with
that i understand that i understand that
sometimes people are campaigning for
reelection and so they just have to take
a poll figure out what's popular however
the flip side of that is a fouchy who
can be so vastly
so incorrect on
nearly everything that he's been
involved with for decades and not lo and
only make more money well only become
only become more profitable only gain
more positions of influences uh
influence in other boards or uh in other
worlds outside of the government there
is no and now picture anthony fauci it's
just because he thrust himself in front
of the spotlight i wish i loved anything
as much as he loves looking at that red
light in front of the camera
but there are thousands of vouchers that
you've never heard about yeah well and
there's people that are largely
unscrutinized because we have to trust
the science and trust the experts and
we're not you're not a scientist you're
not a doctor you don't have a a vagina
you can't talk about these issues you
can't speak you know authoritatively on
anything you're not a menstruating
person stephen well look that's a good
note to leave it on because i do believe
in following the science and if you
believe that uh uh uh uh uh the term i'm
trying to be careful because i don't
want to be having an end here
biological female
which has also been declared to be
offensive uh biological female and
menstruating person look look look
it's menstrual kabuki theater let's uh
youtube piss off
foreign